Speaking of sustainable are you have a showtime special coming out tomorrow
night?
Wow,
that was a great segue.
It's pretty good.
I was,
I should be on radio.
I should get a radio real radio show.
Yeah,
yeah.
Joseline sequitur Rogan Ted.
Yeah.
So do I.
A showtime special tomorrow.
Friday.
What's tomorrow?
The OLED 10th the 10th,
sorry.
Uh,
Friday,
August 10th,
10:00 PM East Coast.
West Coast,
showtime.
It's called keep talking pal.
And so the,
there it is,
10 seconds on that.
They said,
what are you going to name it?
And I said,
keep talking pal.
They go,
what does that mean?
It's just,
it's how you talk yourself in and out of trouble.
Like you're about to get punched out.
Like keep talking pal.
You'll,
if you don't get a laugh,
you're not getting out of this bar.
And that's kind of how I came into talking shows was being as a young guy,
skinny on Ritalin,
not a good fighter,
not a good fighter at all.
Just not into it.
And you know,
the local bully,
I've said something snarky or funny and you know,
all of a sudden he's got me by the scruff of my shirt with a fist in my face.
And the only thing you can do is like imitate him so much that everyone else
laughs and like he has to drop you because he's now like drop ball,
drop your collar,
not your body because you're now making him laugh.
And so when in doubt,
keep talking pal.
And the fact that I have a quote,
comedy special on showtime is so unlikely from some guy from the minimum wage
working world,
I don't believe it myself.
And so they said,
what are you going to call at night?
A lot of these,
you know,
people,
they have a lot of confidence.
I'm going to call it like just truck me and my mighty Wang take this.
Like I don't have any of that.
So like keep talking pal,
because I know I'm really not supposed to be there.
So how did you do your first show?
Like what,
what made you do your first talking show?
$5.
Um,
in 1983,
a little one you on Hudson right off of like about 10 paces north of Santa
Monica Boulevard.
It's like a treat.
The dead ends on to Santa Monica Boulevard.
It was an art space.
They're called the Lasa club and there was a local promoter in town,
amazing guy.
And he would get like 25 people on stage in one night.
Everyone gets five minutes,
it'd be the singer of that band,
the drummer of that band,
that artists,
that poet,
like real artists who speak for a living.
And then the guy with the funny toward journal or the guy from the band that we
all like and he's going to be an idiot for five minutes.
And these shows were really fun cause it just,
people are offstage all night long,
like running off stage and the bass player in black flag truck to cal state and
the Fed,
fantastic intellect.
He would get invited onto these bills.
I would go with him because we were beached guys.
We lived in the sticks and the gigs were in Hollywood.
So we'll go into the big smoke.
We'll go see the big city.
I'd go with him because he had the band van,
he'd go into town,
I'd tag along.
So He'd read out of some notebook has apocalyptic rantings and one night the
promoter said you got a big mouth next week,
you five minutes or like would have seven minutes,
five bucks.
All I could think of was the five bucks and like what I could,
because we're starving.
Yeah.
As any band was.
And so the next show I got onstage at Lasa told a story that what had happened
at band practice the day before where a white supremacy in a car tried to run
over our guitar player.
Cause we had brown skinned people at our band practice.
And so he yelled,
he accused our guitar player of being a lover and tried to run him over on his
way to the liquor store to get some orange juice.
So our guitar player comes back a little shaken and nearly got run over by a Neo
Nazi and let's go back to practice.
And so for us,
that was as Tuesday and the life of black flag for an audience,
they're like,
oh,
you,
your jaws hit the ground.
And then I read something I'd written,
I go,
well,
my five minutes are up,
or whatever it was,
and I left the stage and it felt right.
I felt like a fish dropped into water for the first time.
Like,
Hey,
I'm a fish.
Like I didn't have a band,
but I had no stage fright and this me and a microphone,
it felt more natural than music ever felt,
which was cool to do,
but never felt natural.
Just felt like,
is it this thing is in me,
has got to come out.
I'm serving a monster where the talking shows like,
yeah,
this is me.
And after the show people came up and said,
what's your next show?
I said,
well,
I'm leaving on tour.
They go,
no,
when you're just talking.
I said,
well,
no,
that's a one off.
I got this $5 bill.
I'm Outta here.
And so the agent that the promoter guy said,
okay,
you're very good at that.
You're a natural.
So how about this?
I promote all these different poets and performance artists.
I'll get you,
I'll give you 20 bucks,
you'll do 20 minutes opening for this guy.
Okay.
So I,
you know,
did 20 minutes and then after a handful of those shows,
those poet types we're opening for me because the black flag aspect kicks in
like almost a dude from black flag people show up.
And I guess I was good enough.
And so those poets weren't that happy like I Mao opening for this guy.
Okay.
And that was 83 turning into 84 by 85 I had gone to Europe for some poetry
festival,
which I kind of blabbed on to in Holland.
I had done a cross country tour,
12 to 50 people in night's sleep on the promoters couch go by Amtrak and started
my little book company or 83 84 self published to this day.
That's awesome.
And it went from strength to strength and now it's a 14 month tour that takes in
20 countries,
multiple nights in cities at nice theaters.
Do you only use yourself for your publishing company or do you publish anybody
else's books?
We used to,
uh,
many years ago we,
I uh,
people I knew who I thought were great writers,
I put them out.
We licensed nick caves books from his publishers in Europe.
Uh,
we licensed a few different titles.
We did photo books and a couple of novels,
short story collections.
And it's very hard to,
uh,
have a book company.
It's hard to sell a book in the world unless it's like Stephen King or Danielle
Steele x Mega,
you know,
at the,
at the cash register at the airport store.
Uh,
if you're selling poetry books,
different kinds of literature,
you are nothing but uphill.
My books did okay.
They still,
they always do.
Okay.
Everyone else's books is like trying to sell dead animal guts,
you know what I mean?
Like no one,
no one's that interested.
They'll look but they don't want to take it home.
And so,
um,
we stopped signing new writers,
sold through the press runs,
let the licenses run out.
Everyone got to keep their masters.
And then we just concentrated on me because a,
I keep a whole staff busy with all this stuff I've got going.
And so we publish,
but we publish me and I've done a bunch of books.
How many books have you written?
About 27.
Holy Shit.
I got nothing else going on.
Uh,
all the two of them.
we,
I wanted to do a photo book a few years ago and Heidi,
who runs all my company,
she's the smart one.
So I showed her the manuscript,
she goes,
okay,
the book is great,
but let's not do it on our company cause it's a lot of startup money for a photo
book.
It's just a lot of setup costs.
Let's get you a literary agent and do it somewhere else.
And so smart idea.
And so we got a literary agent and we did get a book deal with a very good,
uh,
Chicago,
as a Chicago Company,
um,
Chicago review,
I'm forgetting.
Um,
and they put out the photo book and that was a learning experience.
Like working with an editor.
Like I'll go,
go,
well,
here's the cover.
And they,
well we're going to have a meeting about that.
And I'm like,
you're having a meeting.
It's my book.
It's my book cover.
Cause I'm used to owning my own machine.
But when you work with other people's money,
everyone has a big opinion.
So that,
that book came out and did and continues to do very well.
And many years ago I did a kind of a best of,
if I have any best of material,
I did a best of for random house many,
many years ago that you still see it.
It's in print.
And that's a lot of people's first book of mine cause it's in stores.